[Musique]
il est 13h30 tout pile bienvenue dans
politique week-end tout de suite c'est
l'heure du duel se font face aujourd'hui
et va ça se député Europe Écologie les
vertus de Paris et Richard Ramos député
moderne du Loiret bonjour à tous les
deux merci de participer à ce débat nous
sommes toujours accompagnés
Delpech et c'est donc parti pour le duel
alors que l'uniforme fait de nouveau
débats en France avec cette fois-ci
cette députés Renaissance qui s'empare
du sujet et prépare une proposition de
loi pour favoriser je cite le port d'une
tenue scolaire commune la question est
donc la suivante faut-il imposer
l'uniforme à l'école vous avez chacun
une minute pour défendre votre position
Richard Ramos vous commencez moi je suis
vous m'auriez posé la même question il y
a 10 ans j'étais contre aujourd'hui je
suis pour pourquoi parce qu'il faut
resacraliser l'école c'est-à-dire que je
pense que l'école aujourd'hui qui était
un outil moi je suis un fils d'ouvrir la
cité on respectait l'école on respectait
les enseignants il y avait quelque chose
de sacralisé dans l'école et aujourd'hui
je pense que finalement on s'aperçoit
que avant on était dans un milieu social
avec ce qu'on mangeait aujourd'hui on
pense qu'on devient riche et du milieu
social supérieur en customisant ses
baskets et parce qu'on le fait qu'on
soit habillé et donc moi je pense que si
tout le monde est habillé de la même
façon payé par l'Éducation nationale
évidemment alors là finalement on remet
les égalités finalement parce que tout
le monde est habillé de la même façon et
également je n'aurais pas dit ça il y a
quelques années on a besoin de redonner
à l'école quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre d'une importance vraiment
particulière et donc je pense que c'est
un détail à personne qui nous arrête
dans la rue pour dire il faut l'uniforme
à l'école mais je pense que c'est un
détail qui peut faire en sorte que
l'école retrouve je dirais quelque chose
qui est particulier et que le bien
commun et si c'est l'uniforme et bien
tant mieux j'ai débord mais on est bien
et bah ça c'est à vous une minute
bah ça paraît une bonne idée ça mais
c'est une fausse bonne solution d'abord
c'est vouloir revenir à un passé qui n'a
pas existé en fait qui est fantasmé qui
est nostalgique et la blouse n'a en fait
jamais été obligatoire à l'école les
écoliers mettaient simplement une gousse
pour éviter les tâches d'encre et
protéger leurs vêtements parce que à
l'époque c'était cher ensuite on propose
le retour à l'école pardon mais c'est la
un peu une ancienne pour quand on a
aucune idée sur l'école à proposer
parlons des vrais problèmes parlons de
la mixité sociale parlons de la carte
scolaire parlons de l'égalité des
chances voilà les vrais sujets je pense
que là on essaye de se cacher derrière
son petit doigt et de proposer des
choses qui paraissent simples mais en
fait qui ne résolvent aucun problème
ensuite ça correspond vraiment pas du
tout à l'aspiration de la jeunesse
aujourd'hui et à l'époque je pense que
c'est là aussi un petit peu nostalgique
laissons les enfants s'habiller comme
ils veulent et puis parlons pédagogie
parlons des vrais problèmes de l'école
là je crois qu'on pourra avoir un vrai
débat sur les vrais sujets
parfait merci à tous les deux Chabot
c'est une fausse bonne idée
c'est une idée qui effectivement traîne
depuis très très longtemps j'aime
beaucoup on dit plus uniforme j'ai bien
compris on dit une tenue scolaire
commune voilà ce que dit Sylvain en
effet voilà c'est mieux comme ça on
donne pas le scientifiquement voilà ça
il ferait moins mais c'est vrai que ça
pourrait résoudre un certain nombre de
problèmes on voit envoyer laïcité oui
les tenues qui renvoient des convictions
religieuses serait ainsi effectivement
beaucoup plus les cas seraient beaucoup
plus facilement traité donc ça c'est un
intérêt et moi je crois aussi à
l'égalité sociale c'est vrai qu'il y a
des compétitions sur les marques dans
les cours de récréation donc moi je
pense que ça remet tout le monde à peu
près au même niveau c'est pas une
humiliation après jusqu'au faut-il aller
primaire facile secondaire jusque la
classe de seconde jusqu'en terminale et
ça peut être effectivement accepté à
condition d'être expliqué c'est pas une
nostalgie il faut dire qu'aujourd'hui il
y a des tas de pays dans le monde
partout euh non surtout les continents
où les enfants portent des uniformes
qu'ils soient dans des écoles
religieuses ou dans des écoles publiques
c'est la règle et elle est acceptée par
tout le monde
alors moi ça fait des années vous
parliez tout à l'heure monsieur le
député vous disiez que il y a 10 ans
vous étiez pas favorable à l'uniforme
j'ai envie de dire que de temps perdu
parce que ça fait bien plus de 10 ans
que moi je défends cette proposition et
les républicains avaient repris
également cette proposition évidemment à
l'époque c'était des ringards des reaks
et des ultras conservateurs nous avons
perdu du temps parce que l'uniforme est
un est un est un élément qui permet de
recréer de l'égalité d'effacer les
différences sociales qui sont qui
existent aussi à l'école qui peuvent
être aussi à la source à harcèlement
scolaire et ça c'est un élément qui est
quand même pas négligeable qui permet de
créer de la cohésion entre les élèves et
qui permet de lutter contre le
prosélytisme religieux qui se fait aussi
à travers des vêtements et différentes
études vous montrer qu'il y avait une
montée en puissance des vêtements
religieux notamment des abayas et des
camises donc des vêtements religieux
islamiques au sein de l'école et on a
des difficultés à les combattre
l'uniforme peut aussi être une solution
ne nous cachons pas derrière notre petit
doigt pour remettre un peu de neutralité
religieuse refaire respecter la laïcité
à l'école pour que l'école redevienne un
sanctuaire voire un asile involable
comme dit j'ai Janzé et je crois que
c'est indispensable de remettre
l'uniforme à l'école que ce soit la
blouse ou une tenue complète qu'importe
ça sera également moi j'y suis sensible
parce que je suis su d'un milieu modeste
ça sera également un moyen de soulager
des parents qui n'ont pas la possibilité
d'être dans dans la course aux marques
aux vêtements ça sera un soulagement
financier et je pense que des parties de
gauche devraient être sensibles aussi à
cet argument il devrait les soutenir
Richard rameau s'est ensuite evaçage ou
de droite je pense que sur ce sujet là
d'ailleurs nous dans la ruralité on n'a
pas de problème donc
mais la preuve on peut avoir des gens
qui sont plutôt du centre ou de ou de
gauche et qui sont favorables à
l'uniforme donc ça veut dire que on est
capable d'aller dans ce sens là et puis
je vous dis cette histoire ça protège du
religieux nous les ruraux c'est pas un
sujet ça c'est un sujet un argument pour
vous mais ça peut être l'égalité mais ça
peut être un argument dans politique
mais nous on a dans la vraie vie dans la
dans la France profonde c'est pas c'est
pas le sujet par contre le vrai sujet
c'est les inégalités sociales c'est le
fait en fait que quand vous avez une
femme qui est dans la ruralité qui
travaille seule et qui a pas les moyens
d'habiller son gosse et 40% gosse et
bien je me dis que l'uniforme ça lui
permettra aussi de mettre son gosse à
égalité dans l'école et donc évidemment
que c'est pas le sujet le principal de
l'école parce qu'il faut qu'on sorte de
l'école en ressachant compte et lire et
c'est au moins aussi important voire
plus important mais c'est un élément qui
à mon avis de cohésion sociale et
surtout très très important pour moi de
refaire de l'école un lieu je suis
d'Orléans donc janz à part également un
lieu qui est sacralisé et un lieu auquel
on peut redonner je dirais quelque chose
d'une forme de petite autorité parce que
c'est aussi dire à l'enfant tu ne peux
pas tout faire on t'impose une petite
règle tu l'acceptes et c'est la même et
surtout c'est ce qui est important c'est
la même pour tous ce signe une question
d'éducation c'est aussi une question
d'éducation bien évidemment ce que vous
avancez c'est aussi ce que dit Sylvain
Maillard le président par intérim du
groupe Renaissance à l'Assemblée
nationale dans les colonnes du Figaro le
port d'une tenue scolaire commune donc
comme vous le soulignez Arlette Chabot
permet de lutter contre le harcèlement
scolaire c'est pas un argument qui vous
convaincre et bah ça se le harcèlement
scolaire le harcèlement scolaire c'est
un vrai sujet mais je ne compte pas que
ce soit la meilleure façon de le
combattre je crois que là on va il y
aura de toute façon des différents ça ne
va pas effacer la différence et ça ne va
pas malheureusement pourquoi pas mettre
fin à la stigmatisation parce qu'il y a
toujours des éléments différenciation et
les éléments différenciation ils sont
principalement d'ailleurs culturelles où
est-ce que vous êtes partis en vacances
la façon dont vous mangez et les
les baskets tout ça va demeurer il y
aura toujours une différence sociale la
vraie question c'est celle de la mixité
sociale au sein des établissements en
plus la proposition qui est faite là
c'est d'avoir un ami ferme par
établissement cité que ceux qui sont
dans les lycées auront l'uniforme qui
marque encore plus le fait qu'ils
appartiennent à un milieu social
favorisé par abord à d'autres lycées ou
au contraire ils auront l'uniforme qui
marque le fait qu'ils sont dans un lycée
où il a malheureusement plus de classe
défavorisées donc je pense que c'est
exactement l'inverse en fait qui va
arriver travaillons vraiment sur la
question de la mixité sociale au sein
des établissements parce que ça c'est un
vrai sujet ça veut dire qu'il faut
retravailler la carte scolaire ça c'est
un vrai sujet il faut retravailler
l'égalité des chances et ça veut dire
que travailler la pédagogie avoir
des marques à l'école ça peut créer en
français entre les élèves et que des
élèves en souffrent et que il y aura
toujours des marques à l'école il y aura
toujours d'autres éléments culturels
comme je le disais
en attendant vous préférez ne rien faire
en attendant qu'il y ait ces
transformations pédagogiques cette
mixité qu'on revoit la carte scolaire
l'uniforme qui peut améliorer sans doute
à la marge les choses vous préférez ne
pas utiliser ce moyen qui améliorera
c'est tout à fait illusoire et que ça ne
résout rien et c'est justement ça
détourne l'attention des vrais sujets et
qu'il faut à s'attaquer au vrai sujet et
vous dites en attendant pourquoi
attendre non attaquons-nous à la
question pédagogique ne va pas mettons
par exemple dans les classes ce que vous
proposez prend beaucoup de temps
l'uniforme ça peut être désolé je suis
désolé
au pire ce dont vous ça servira à rien
mais c'est mais ça peut pas être négatif
mais je vous ai dit c'est pas moi je
suis pas je suis pas contre dans
l'absolu je trouve que juste on détourne
l'attention des vrais sujets c'est ça le
vrai problème sinon voilà ça peut ça
c'est pour ça que c'est séduisant c'est
séduisant mais c'est pas une baguette
magique qui va régler les problèmes je
suis un peu de la vie de
dévassa c'est à dire que c'est
effectivement quelque chose qui sort le
papier c'est très séduisant c'est très
bien ça peut c'est voilà mais d'abord un
il y a l'acceptabilité ce que les jeunes
générations on a envie ça il faudrait
leur poser la question pour commencer on
va faire de l'école un lieu il faut
d'abord poser la question première chose
deuxième chose ça va coûter très cher
parce que il faut fournir un uniforme ou
plusieurs uniformes à chaque élève
est-ce que je pose la question est-ce
que ce budget on consacrerait à
l'uniforme pas mieux le consacrer à
augmenter les salaires des professeurs
ou avoir plus de professeurs et puis la
troisième chose la troisième chose c'est
que autant je comprends l'argument sur
la sacralisation de l'école c'est vrai
qu'il y a un véritable besoin en France
de resacraliser l'école ça c'est une
chose mais utilisez l'argument de
l'uniforme pour résoudre la question du
port des des vêtements religieux à
l'école ça c'est une hypocrisie totale
soit on fait une loi et on interdit et
mais on et on fait appliquer
l'interdiction des des vêtements
religieux à l'école et on le fait et
c'est assumé et c'est fait mais se
servir du port de l'uniforme pour
empêcher de venir avec savoir
que quelqu'un vient avec uniforme et un
voile par-dessus uniforme c'est
l'argument de dire qu'il s'adresse ou
absolument pas cette question du des
vêtements religieux à l'école et c'est à
mon avis très hypocrite de s'appuyer sur
l'uniforme qui permettrait d'empêcher de
venir avec des vêtements religieux avec
quoi soit on assume et on fait une loi
contre les vêtements religieux à l'école
et elle est appliquée soit et ben on
laisse les choses alors le fait de dire
que l'argent qui serait mis dedans on
paierait les professeurs c'est
complètement démago ça coûte rien quand
on voit le budget d'éducation nationale
est-ce que coûterait l'uniforme c'est
rien mais ce que je crois moi vraiment
c'est que l'uniforme n'empire les élèves
seraient pas d'accord mais c'est parce
que on a toujours dit les élèves sont
pas d'accord qu'on en est arrivé à la
décan de l'école française ça veut dire
que aujourd'hui on doit être capable de
dire dans une école il y a on te demande
pas si tu es d'accord il y a un
règlement pour y rentrer tu l'acceptes
parce que le problème c'est ça c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui rien n'est accepté
moi vous savez je vais vous raconter une
toute petite anecdote normalement quand
on est en primaire quand vous avez bien
travaillé en français en mathématiques
le professeur met des carrés et moins
vous avez bien travaillé vous enlevez
les bars des carrés et un jour je vois
une élève où il y avait que des carrés
et je sais que c'est une élève en
difficulté je dis mais pourquoi il y a
des carrés élastiques me répond parce
que je veux pas être emmerdé avec les
parents ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que si on fait pas de l'école un lieu de
des règles il faut le même uniforme en
France parce que l'école elle est unique
elle est la même sur le territoire
français il faut il faut le mettre il
faut le même uniforme partout en France
parce que l'école elle les programmes
doivent être les mêmes on doit pas avoir
des chances différentes à Neuilly qu'on
en aurait à l'Argonne dans la cité mais
là-dessus qu'il faut se battre et je
pense que l'uniforme même si on débat
sur ce sujet qui est évidemment n'est
pas le sujet principal moi je pense que
c'est un vrai élément de le lien et de
faire en sorte qu'on porte au même
moment dans la même classe dans la
République française l'éducation
républicaine le même vêtement votre
réponse après en avance non mais une
fois de plus vous l'avez dit déjà sur la
question des signes religieux la loi de
2004 existe il faut et peut-être la
préciser sur la question des abeilles
puisque c'est un peu le sujet donc
l'éléphant au milieu de la pièce dont
personne ne parle là et ne pas laisser
d'ailleurs les proviseurs seuls
désemparés devant ce sujet qui ne
peuvent pas traiter seuls et donc il
faut que le ministère précise cette
question mais la loi existe de 2004
personne ne la remet en cause c'est un
bon compromis dans la société je pense
qui simplement il faut il faut
l'appliquer après vous le dites il faut
avoir les mêmes chances à Neuilly et en
Seine-Saint-Denis mais enfin évidemment
il n'y a pas les mêmes chances donc
travaillons justement sur ce vrai sujet
qui est pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas
les mêmes chances aujourd'hui à Neuilly
ou dans Seine-Saint-Denis travaillons
sur le fait que le capital culturel est
trop discriminant à l'école et qu'il
faut des enseignements qui soient
inclusifs ce qu'on appelle l'accrochage
scolaire c'est à dire que les élèves qui
sont en difficulté ils doivent trouver
leur place dans l'école ça c'est des
vrais sujets au lieu d'avoir des pardons
mais des discussions cosmétiques sur
quelque chose qui ne va rien régler déjà
à l'inclusion à l'école le fait d'avoir
des programmes qui soient à peu près
adaptés aux populations tout ça existe
déjà moi je le vécu en tant qu'élève à
Roubaix je pense que les photos sont
sont sont tout à fait qualifiés pour
adapter à la marge parce que le
programme est unique en France aux
élèves qu'ils ont en phase 2 on verra ce
qu'il en est en tout cas
oui c'est vrai que ce sont des sujets
passionnés justement on va rester un peu
dans dans le thème très passionné
c'était l'assemblée qui a été très
passionné cette semaine plongée dans le
chaudron de l'hémicycle ça fait deux
nuits qu'il est en ébullition la nuit
dernière bise répétita d'ailleurs pour
la première ministre Elisabeth borne qui
a dégainé pour la sixième fois le 49-3
sur fond de tension pour faire adopter
le projet de budget de la sécurité
sociale
cette semaine l'a montré à partir de
désaccords légitimes nous pouvons
basculer dans des jeux de rôles voir des
pugilats mais je suis convaincu que nous
avons encore l'occasion et je dirais
même chacun avec nos convictions la
volonté de répondre à l'attente des
Français et de faire de cette assemblée
l'épicentre du compromis
mesdames et messieurs les députés je ne
me résous pas à la litanie des 49-3
suivi d'émotions de censure
litanie des 49-3 suivi d'émotions de
censure c'est vrai qu'il y a aussi eu
une nouvelle motion de censure de la
France insoumise la sixième là encore de
la France insoumise voilà ce que tweet
d'ailleurs Mathilde panot la présidente
du groupe LFI à l'Assemblée nationale en
49-3 pour commencer la semaine un second
pour la terminer le sixième en un mois
pour sanctionner chaque récidive
d'obstruction gouvernementale nous
déposerons une motion de censure déjà
Eva ça est-ce que vous constatez une
ambiance qui est de plus en plus
délétère à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
vrai qu'il y a une ambiance tendue mais
il y a aussi des choses intéressantes
qui se passent à l'Assemblée peut-être
plus que dans d'autres mandatures
l'ambiance allait tendue parce que il y
a on ne se sent pas respecté en tant que
parlementaire je pense que c'est ça le
problème principal quand on vote des
amendements par exemple à la majorité je
pense évidemment la maman la rénovation
thermique que j'ai que j'ai porté ou sur
le ferroviaire ou si par exemple la
transformation de la réduction d'impôts
pour les EHPAD en crédit d'impôt ce qui
est favorable à la prise en charge de la
dépendance pour les non imposable donc
vraiment des sujets consensuels que
l'assemblée porte de façon
transpartisanale et adopte à la majorité
et que ce n'est pas repris dans le 49.3
donc là il y a un vrai problème de déni
de démocratie c'est le déni de
démocratie c'est pas tant d'ailleurs le
49-3 c'est le fait que dans le test qui
est repris à 49-3 il ne tiennent pas
compte des sentiments de travailler dans
le videment qui ont été votés par la
majorité de l'Assemblée et attention de
façon transpartisanale on reproche
toujours aux députés de faire du théâtre
alors que là au contraire on a travaillé
de façon consensuelle et il y a
plusieurs amendements comme ça de mon
sens j'ai envie de dire qui ont émergé
de ce travail parlementaire et ce n'est
pas respecté par le gouvernement donc là
oui il y a un sentiment de violence on
l'a vu encore avec la corrida pardon
mais la discussion sur la proposition de
loi d'abolition de la corrida on a une
obstruction parlementaire de certains
députés là en l'occurrence anticorida
qui déposent près de 500 amendements
pour empêcher que le texte soit discuté
et adopté là je pense que là aussi il y
a un sentiment vraiment de Louis de
violence et d'obstruction qui fait qu'on
ne peut pas faire notre travail de
parlementaire correctement donc ça ça
engendre des tensions bon je fais pas
partie de ceux qui crient dans
l'hémicycle ni qui dépasse les bornes
jamais parce que c'est pas ma nature et
pas ma façon de fonctionner mais c'est
vrai que je constate que ça crée
forcément des tensions parce qu'on a
envie de travailler dans des conditions
plus sereine et qui est plus et bataille
d'obstruction ces batailles
d'obstruction ou qu'elle participe
parfois le gouvernement lui-même en
ralentissant les débats volontairement
pour que certains textes ne soient pas
examinés sur l'obstruction c'est
l'hôpital qui se fout de la charité
parce que 500 500 amendements sur la
corrida la France insoumise depuis 6 ans
c'était des milliers des dizaines de
milliers d'obstructions non mais c'est
la nupèce pour nous c'est c'est la
nupaisse les écologistes on va dire vous
venez d'arriver mais c'est c'était
vraiment incroyable et en plus sur la
corrida comme Monsieur Caron fait sa
proposition de loi au moment où il sait
qu'elle va pas être votée qui sera pas
majoritaire alors que tout le monde a
travaillé alors que le Parlement a mis
des amendements il la retire donc comme
le centre démocratie il y a mieux moi ce
que je voulais vous dire simplement sur
l'ambiance à l'Assemblée quand on est
sur un travail parlementaire et qu'on
oublie 2027 on est capable de travailler
sur des sujets il faut que le Parlement
fasse des petits pieds de nez ou
gouvernement quel qu'il soit pour qu'on
fasse un travail parlementaire moi il y
a un mois je faisais un texte sur le
désengriagement de la France et
notamment de la Sologne qui était
compliqué entre les chasseurs les
écologistes madame madame belluco j'ai
fait 100% des voix
90 votants 90 pour j'ai fait un travail
parlementaire je me je me projette pas
dans 2027 avec les chefs à plumes qui
valaient tous président de la République
il faut que on puisse travailler comme
c'est le cas au Parlement européen sur
un vrai travail parlementaire et là on
retrouvera moi je suis allé avec
Sébastien Jumel communiste défendent
cette pêche de scène qui s'est chalutier
qui vont qui vont empêcher nos petits
pêcheurs de pêcher c'est ça le travail
parlementaire et donc si on revient dans
la nouvelle configuration un travail
parlementaire inter-groupe auquel on
peut trouver des choses qui s'est pas
qui n'est pas le grand soir mais
peut-être le petit matin alors on
trouvera une voie parlementaire qui fait
qu'on n'aura pas ce qu'on a dans
l'hémicycle et moi je le regarde chez
moi les gens sont effarés les gens me
disent mais vous n'êtes pas sérieux vous
vous rendez compte mais comment comment
voulez-vous qu'on explique à nos jeunes
qu'il faut qu'il parle bien alors que
vous-même vous ne faites que vous
invectiver et donc tout ça c'est pour
une raison simple c'est que on est en
2022 ils sont tous déjà dans ce cas bois
en 2027 non on va faire un travail
parlementaire et on trouvera les voix et
moyen de trouver des consensus dans ce
Parlement c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on
travaille et avec les LR inclus arrête
Chabot vous qui êtes une une fine
observatrice de de observatrice de la
vie politique depuis un peu plus
longtemps que moi est-ce que vous avez
déjà vu un climat aussi délétère aussi
explosif à l'Assemblée nationale que ce
qu'on a vu ces deux dernières nuits
n'a jamais vu je pense alors il y a eu
des choses violentes on va pas dire ça
commence depuis 3 mois ou six mois il y
a eu des échanges très violents la
disons que ça ça dérape à nouveau dans
un climat effectivement qui est assez
désagréable et qui donne surtout aux
Français et là je pense que vous êtes
tous les deux d'accord une mauvaise
image du Parlement si les Français ont
voté de cette manière c'est pour tout le
monde soit représenté sans la
proportionnelle tout le monde est dedans
après discuter des battais trouver des
compromis c'est ça qui est Français
veulent ils ne veulent pas le dérapage
ils ne veulent pas de ce qui apporte une
confusion totale en plus et on ne
s'intéresse qu'à ça donc je pense que ça
c'est tout à fait regrettable après les
échanges violents il y a même qui se
terminaient dans dans des républiques
précédentes avec un duel entre des
parlementaires ça avait un peu de
panache ça pouvait mal finir mais là là
c'est surtout ce brouhaha cette
effervescence qui ne débouche sur rien
je pensais que le parlementaire de la
majorité qui est à ma gauche je voulais
dire je regrette aussi que le
gouvernement reprenne pas les
amendements de sa majorité voilà il y a
que ça ferait un point d'accord et je
pense évidemment à la taxation des super
dividendes absolument ah oui cette
taxation des super dividendes voulu par
le modèle mais le président Mattei pour
moi c'est une humiliation du
gouvernement que de la balayer et que de
temps en temps que je suis en colère
Bruno Le Maire je l'appelle Nono voilà
et je dis mais qui regarde un petit peu
qui regarde un petit peu ce qui se passe
nous ce qu'on a fait on a porté quelque
chose qui était
attendu dans le pays c'est la justice
qui est attendue donc quand il y a des
gens qui font des supers super super
dividendes et des gens qui crèvent la
fin quelle que soit le bord politique je
pense que ça ça aurait dû être pris et
c'est vrai que quand quelque chose a été
voté par l'ensemble des parlementaires
et que derrière même quand on est dans
la majorité présidentielle c'est balayé
d'un revers de main ça veut dire qu'on
Bafou quelque part la démocratie et le
peuple français alors la meilleure
illustration de ce n'est pas plus que
houle à l'Assemblée nationale c'était
dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi sur le
débat de la réintégration des soignants
non vacciné contre le covid-19 en
vective insulte vous allez les entendre
il y a un porte-parole du gouvernement
un peu choqué atterré par l'ambiance
écoutez
tu vas la fermer
non c'est pas possible non monsieur
serveur je m'étonne un tout petit peu
honnêtement du niveau de tension que je
n'ai jamais vu en 12 ans de Parlement
et j'aurais aimé mesdames et messieurs
les députés des oppositions que vous
mettiez la même énergie le même
enthousiasme et la même volonté de bien
faire lorsqu'il fallait voter des
mesures difficiles pour protéger les
Français tels que les couvre-feu les
confinements ou pourquoi pas le quoi
qu'il en coûte
mon précise donc Olivier Servane
s'adressait pas Olivier Véran Olivier
Vérand le porte-parole du gouvernement
qui lui aussi était largement interpellé
derrière et c'est pour ça que il a eu
cette cette déclaration Frédéric Delpech
vous qui est souvent à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est vrai qu'on a parfois le
sentiment ces derniers jours que la
forme prime un peu sur le fond oui alors
c'est pas non plus nouveau on a enfin
rappelez-vous les débats sur le PACS
enfin et j'en passe et des meilleurs
donc ça a quand même il y a toujours une
forme de tension à l'Assemblée là c'est
vrai qu'elle est exacerbée mais je
dirais pas que c'est les députés qui
sont plus agressifs que ceux qui
existent avant c'est simplement que le
paysage politique est totalement nouveau
on avait l'habitude en France pendant
des années d'avoir une sorte
d'alternance tantôt LPS tantôt l'UMP ou
le RPR enfin selon le selon l'époque
avec tantôt la droite tantôt la gauche
et puis ça se retrouvait également à
l'Assemblée l'assemblée elle bascule
d'un côté ou l'autre là on est dans un
paysage nouveau il y a pas de majorité
absolue pour le gouvernement il y a un
rassemble national très puissant à
l'Assemblée il y a une nouvelle
formation qui s'appelle la nupesse très
puissante aussi également à l'Assemblée
puis les deux anciens partis bah eux qui
qui sont réduits à peau de chagrin le PS
et les républicains donc plus alors on
met maintenant la majorité centrale de
d'Emmanuel Macron qui est très disparate
également donc on a un paysage politique
inédit on n'est plus du tout dans le
Bipolaris mais on est dans le quadrille
partiis ou peut-être même plus
d'ailleurs et donc forcément cette
confusion politique elle se retrouve à
l'Assemblée et donc c'est vrai qu'elle
agressivité c'est vrai qu'il y a de la
tension il y a même des des des gros
politiques comme LFI qui revendiquent
une stratégie de l'attention ça c'est
clair et net pas les écologistes mais en
tout cas le groupe LFI avec parfois
d'avenir d'ailleurs on envoie presque
toutes les semaines ok tout ça c'est
vrai mais ça reflète sans doute une un
paysage politique explosé morcelé et
avec une ligne directrice que les
Français ont du mal à comprendre alors
ils sont la forme de côté sur le fond
justement pour ou contre la
réintégration des soignants dessiner
contre le covid-19 écoutons d'abord
Emmanuel Macron contre bien évidemment
qui plaît de l'argument scientifique
mais ça n'a pas été une décision en
opportunité politique au moment où ce
choix a été fait ça a été une décision
scientifiquement établie sur une
recommandation scientifique d'un conseil
indépendant
et donc il faut que la décision soit
scientifiquement établie si les
scientifiques aujourd'hui et les
médecins et les soignants nous disent
c'est souhaitable d'un point de vue
scientifique de réintégrer ces soignants
il faut que le gouvernement le fasse ça
n'est pas un choix politique
Richard Amos donc pour ou contre moi je
suis contre la réintégration il faut
regarder par contre là où il y aurait de
la télémédecine comment on peut
réfléchir là où c'est possible mais je
suis je suis contre parce que d'abord il
y a eu un acide scientifique et puis
après on est aussi des élus de
territoire moi dans un EHPAD il n'est
pas de il y a eu quelqu'un que je
connaissais qui est décédé et dont on
peut penser que le personnel l'avait
transmis et donc parce qu'ils avaient
fermé aux familles et donc voilà je
pense que il faut un moment à donner à
assumer par contre il faut regarder là
où on pourrait faire de la télémédecine
s'il y a des possibilités en
bienveillance également il suffit pas de
de mettre les uns contre les autres mais
on peut pas pour mettre à profit à
profil qui ont fait des études
exactement ces compétences ces profils
donc il y a peut-être des possibilités
je le pense moi de les réintégrer dans
le processus mais on peut pas quand on
est soignant se dire que on va faire
courir un risque à celui qu'on soigne
moi c'est c'est relativement simple donc
je suis vraiment contre le fait qu'on
les réintègre mais qu'on regarde parce
que dans mon terr par exemple on me dit
qu'il y a en télétravail des manques et
bien regardons comment c'est possible ne
faisons pas non plus une bagarre
idéologique essayons de trouver
concrètement des solutions
de la gauche vous êtes contre aussi
alors le groupe est très partagé mais
moi je suis effectivement contre la
réintégration des soignants non vaccinés
pour la même raison pour la protection
des patients d'abord et avant tout et il
y a toujours eu des obligations
vaccinales donc si on fait une
différence sur le vaccin contre le covid
ça veut dire qu'on met en cause
ce vaccin en particulier donc il est la
vraie discussion qu'il faut avoir il
faut la clarifier mais si on a confiance
dans ce vaccin alors à ce moment-là
cette obligation vaccinale elle doit
elle doit prévaloir comme pour les
autres vaccins qui sont obligatoires
pour les professionnels de santé après
c'est vrai que chez nous le groupe est
partagé pourquoi parce qu'il y a la
question de la pénurie des soignants
donc forcément ça incite à faire revenir
les soignants non vaccinés à l'hôpital
parce qu'il y en a il y en a vraiment
besoin notamment dans les départements
d'outre-mer parce que là la question est
vraiment très très aiguë là-bas et puis
l'autre question c'est la question
sociale parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a
des soignants qui ne sont pas payés
depuis des mois et ça c'est ce n'est pas
acceptable non plus donc une fois de
plus il faut le faire effectivement avec
bienveillance mais ne pas mettre en
danger la santé des patients mais
d'autant que sur la réintégration pour
citer le chiffre de la Fédération
spécialière de France il y a quelques
jours ils sont au nombre de 4000 parmi
lesquels environ 500 infirmiers c'est
vrai que c'est loin du chiffre de 15000
qui circule beaucoup mais les Russes bah
quand on est face une situation de
pénurie dans l'hôpital on peut
comprendre le besoin de réintégrer aussi
des soignants qui ont été formés ils
sont certes formés mais ils sont
soignants donc ils doivent quand même
croire en la science et et en ce vaccin
comme le rappelait madame la députée des
vaccins obligatoires il y en a beaucoup
il y en a vraiment plusieurs pour les
soignants et il serait incompréhensible
que ce vaccin là contre la covid
devienne un vaccin qui n'est pas
obligatoire ça le remettrait en question
moi je je ne suis pas favorable à la
réintégration des des soignants qui ne
sont pas même si c'est un des rares pays
c'est intégré sauf que il y a une il y a
une règle elle doit être la même pour
tous rappelons-nous des épisodes
notamment dans les EHPAD où il y a eu
des personnes vulnérables et souvent à
l'hôpital ce sont des personnes qui sont
vulnérables qui ont été contaminées par
par du personnel donc nous aujourd'hui
ça c'est incompréhensible que qu'il n'y
ait pas de de vaccination pour ça serait
incompréhensible qu'il y ait des
personnels réintégrés qui ne soient pas
vaccinés merci à tous les cinq de
m'avoir accompagné pour cette émission
pour politique weekend